this is the jocko unraveling podcast
episode five with daryl cooper and me
jocko willink where'd we leave off daryl
you were going home and iraq was just
starting to come apart at the seams
you and your boys took down sauter's
lieutenant the shia rose up
down in the south we had to redirect
forces down there to get them under
control which was a problem because at
the same exact time
we had problems with the sunni
population in the west out in anbar
in fallujah four black water contractors
got lynched mutilated tortured and hung
up on display by
a cheering crowd of of people there
a few days after that we sent a guy
named mattis
and his marines into that city to
retaliate and
um if you tell the marines
that there's people in that city that
killed a bunch of americans and
mutilated and tortured them and hung
them up on display go do something about
it you better provide very specific
orders
because uh the marines are going to tear
somebody up
and um and they went in hard and they
went in fast
and the arab language press just had a
field day with that
start spreading out all over the middle
east all over iraq the americans are
killing civilians they're destroying
indiscriminately
and this is going on right at the time
that the shia uprising is happening in
the south
and so we are split up all over the
country
um you seem to focus a lot on the shia
uprising on the south which was
definitely a
a real problem but
when if the first thing that pops into
my mind when you talk about the shia
uprising
is baghdad is solder city that's the
first thing i think about maybe that's
because i was
in baghdad but but also there was a lot
this is what i remember i remember that
sadder city like was immediately there
was a lot of heavy casualties
in sauder city in and around sauder city
to the
uh troops that were out there like right
after
we went and got yakubi so i i part of
it's because it was more visible to me
part of it's because
this is another big thing that that is
always was always evident was
things that happened in baghdad got a
lot of press because it was baghdad the
green zone
you know you'd walk around the green
zone there was reporters and there was
normal you know there was
all kinds of press in the green zone and
that means they're
they're 10 yards from from baghdad
they're in baghdad
and things that were going on in other
parts of the country wouldn't receive as
much press and
you know fallujah had less press ramadi
had even less press
when we when by the time we get to
ramadi in 2006 there was very little
press out in ramadi almost none
i didn't really start to get an idea of
what was going on in ramadi while you
were there until maybe 2009 2010
before i started to read like some of
the longer pieces that start to come out
about what happens yeah and i was
following it pretty close
you know i knew there was some fighting
going on out there the stuff you began
the new york times or the you know wall
street journal but it took a while for
people to really
process what had happened out in ambar
yeah and that's
so so baghdad was baghdad went south
real quick bad dad got bad real quick
after
you know that april and again that's
about the time we're going home
now you know we did we did some turnover
ops with the guys that relieved us
and they were all pretty straightforward
you know it wasn't they weren't looking
around going hey everything's going to
change for us
the ied threat had escalated but it was
still
it wasn't even close to what it turned
into
you know there is a reason that i i tend
to focus on the south a little bit
um and you can tell me if i'm a little
off base here but this is
this was always my perception
is right around the time so let's see uh
back in
august 2003 just before you first showed
up that was when al qaeda and iraq hit
the u.n they hit the jordanian embassy
all the ngos leave the u.n evacuates the
country and they're really working hard
to do
two things one not make this a coalition
war you know where the u.n is present
and overseeing what's going this is the
americans
in there against the muslims against the
iraqis right
and so and they accomplished that in
2003 in a lot of people's minds
and at the same time they start hitting
indiscriminately shia holy sites trying
to foment a civil war so now the
americans are just caught in this
maelstrom right
so that happens back in the fall before
you get there
you're going around hitting targets
doing your thing we're trying to clean
this stuff up as it's starting to
escalate but we don't have a full grasp
of what's going on yet
we think that it's remnants of the
regime who are doing this kind of stuff
we don't have the idea yet really that
there's an insurgency forming an
organized insurgency
we get up to march march 2nd
of 2004 uh maybe march 11th i'm sorry i
don't have it in front of me
and uh the spanish train the madrid
train bombing happens
hundreds of people are killed 2 000
people are killed because al qaeda
in spain hits a train this is a couple
days three days before the spanish
general elections
and it went from a candidate who was the
front-runner who was
supporting america who was on board
and it just swung immediately over to
the anti-war candidate in spain was the
hell out of there
right you had had this movement
like you said every war every conflict
there is
going to be a piece of the population
that just says no
and there's going to be a piece within
that group who doesn't just say no
who says who has the idea that we are
the bad guys here
right and those those people are pretty
tireless
and they're gonna keep working um
as the war starts to go on and things
start to happen
and we start to lose control those
people
start to make inroads into
you know the rest of our own domestic
population their side starts to grow
in europe it's already stronger than it
is here in america the madrid train
bombings happen uh more europeans start
to say uh
i don't know if we really want to be a
piece of a part of this
and when the uh when you guys took down
yakubi
in najaf at the time i mentioned this in
the previous episode
uh you know we because it was a little
bit more pacified down there with the
shia
uh we had the bulgarians the poles a
bunch of our allies coalition allies
down there and they start getting
hammered by sauders forces and they're
getting overrun they're getting pushed
back
and so that's more of our european
allies we're like ugh this is getting a
little bit uglier than we thought and
we're getting a little more isolated
and then we've got to redirect forces
that maybe properly ought to be out in
anbar
keeping you know this is a time where al
qaeda and iraq is starting to
consolidate their control over the rest
of the
sunni insurgency right but we've got to
redirect to go support
our coalition allies in the south now
and it's funny because
you know i just i look at maps of iraq
and stuff i didn't realize that najaf is
a five-hour drive down there
you know i think it's maybe 150 200
miles or something but you know we're
not all driving on interstate five
yeah and again you're talking about
driving in humvees and they're they're
slower
you know um they you know we're going
usually 55 miles an hour
you know that's like flat out you know
maybe we get to 60 but pretty much
you're going 55 60 miles an hour
right and also there was uh you know
you'd have you'd have to do some
checkpoint stuff along the way we'd we'd
go and check with the battle space so
you know the 200 miles you know what
going 50 miles an hour
you know that's a four-hour drive you
make a stop for fuel you make a because
you know
we're not gonna we're not gonna drive
our vehicles until they're out of fuel
or until we're low on fuel so we'd stop
some
at some fob somewhere get a refuel
and you know check in with some battle
space commander somewhere so that brings
it out that stretches it out there next
thing you know you're looking at yeah
you're looking at five hours
okay so we get to the point now where
we've got our already
a force that our military brass already
thinks is a little bit too low or really
a lot too low to keep
over to provide overall security in the
country now we're split up
over here in anbar down to the south in
the shia areas
our allies because of madrid because of
them getting hammered in the south right
now
because of the marketing of the anti-war
movement in the west
are already starting to lose faith in us
and then in
in april as the country is starting to
spiral we know what's coming there
that's when abu ghraib happens and and
that's kind of the
frame that that i put it in is that
we're we're starting to lose control of
the domestic conversation
um not only in america but within our
european you know with the european
allies as well
with the rest of the world and to the
extent that this becomes an american war
you know an american crusade against the
muslims
and we lose the rest of the coalition um
the the the whole complex the whole the
whole consolation of the war starts to
change
and um
were you aware of any of that like was
was that in your head at all as you were
starting to get ready to leave there in
april
yeah well you know it's a it's a good
indicator and i mentioned this on the
last episode that
when there's the cpa in
the joff is getting overrun so so think
about what that means
the cpa is getting overrun
let everybody know exactly what that
that means so the the
coalition provisional authority it's the
it's the kind of makeshift government
that's running najaf you know there's
different civilian authorities there
iraqi and american and they're trying to
you know trying to rebuild some kind of
a government
and this gets attacked and is about to
be over on meaning that it's going to
get taken over
and the the guys that were there was a
lot of actions a lot of contractors that
were there
um they they were able to defend the
situation
uh but when that's happening
again and i said this on the last
episode they called
me and my guys in baghdad so there is a
multitude
of these foreign you know foreign
military el
units down there on on that road there's
like a road that goes from baghdad
to najaf and along that way you know
when i talk about talk
stopping at checkpoints you know these
were like different nationalities
different countries
you would have their little base we'd
pull in there get fuel whatever
and some of those people had armor and
instead of sending
any of that who are an hour away 40
minutes away
two hours away they take a group of guys
that are in baghdad
with fit with thin skinned humvees to
drive five hours to get rid of who had
just returned
driving five hours down there executing
an op turning around getting home and
now you're getting
yes and you're the best option yeah and
we're the best option and you know
it's it's complementary great thank you
you know i appreciate it
but from a tactical perspective
well well i mean general patton himself
says a good plan executed now is better
than a great plan executed
in a week right well guess what even if
i go right now it's five hours
when it when it when a
building or a compound is under the
threat of being overrun
you're not thinking that they're going
to make it five hours you said
yesterday you used the term was this
what they told you said we need you to
go down there as a qrf
like you were the quick reaction
absolutely you're five hours away we're
five hours away
so you know that's an indicator okay
well
and it was one of those things where you
you know look you're in the you're in
the military
right and you you're thinking yourself
what are these
what is what is the chain of command
thinking they don't get it they don't
understand what's happening
whatever we'll do our job maybe we're
not seeing everything that they're
seeing
so but yeah as i mentioned on the last
episode
as i'm standing um in a tower
looking out at the highway and i see
multiple burning vehicles i
i hadn't we hadn't seen that we had not
seen that type of thing
at all you'd see a vehicle somewhere you
wouldn't look out on the horizon and see
five burning you know smoking vehicles
that had just been
hit with ieds or rpgs and are now
now under attack so
yeah i could tell it was getting bad and
and again as i said on the last episode
you if you asked me
march 1st if i would ever be coming back
to iraq
as a as a combat leader i would have
said probably not this would be mopped
up
if you ask me april 15th i'd say
we might be back here when
did you have a sense of um and i would
understand if this wasn't the case did
you have a sense of
the public mood shifting um especially
when abu ghraib happened like did you
have a moment
when abu ghraib happened where you know
were you just so in the military world
at that point where you were just like
what are these guys doing what are those
you know mps thinking or did you have a
sense of like oh this is not good
yeah i knew it was not good yeah i knew
it was not good
there had been some things that had
taken place
where where some things got
caught up by the media uh got captured
by the media
and it was bad um i had a couple
incidents that happened
where we you know we didn't look good
and absolutely tiny in comparison
but enough that i said
okay if this if this caused a cause this
much backlash
then what's it what just happened
albuquerque is not going to be good
were you it sounded like when we talked
about it yesterday you had some
experience
like that you must have been in country
at the time because you talked about the
mood of some of the iraqis like seeming
to shift when that happened
um was that something you got when you
returned in 06 or
you're saying that the the mood had
shifted with the uh with some of the
iraqis you were interacting with
yeah you could you could feel it
somewhat it also was very
regional dependent right depending on
where you were
um and it was that was like one of those
just creepy things
you know you'd go through a certain town
certain village
and i remember we went we actually were
on our way i think we were actually on
our way to najaf and
we went through a town you got a map
there of iraq
so i think there's a town called hala
it's on the way down there
and we went through there and yeah
yeah so there was halal we started
driving through there
and there was people there was people as
we started coming into the city
where we hear them uh they're blowing
whistles
and like you're just thinking and then
they're giving you the
the the look of we we don't like you
and you know we get the traffic try we
get caught behind traffic and we're
we're dismounting this is before we had
armored vehicles so when we would stop
the vehicles
almost every time if the vehicles were
held up we'd dismount and get away from
the vehicles because the vehicles were
kind of bullet magnets and
and rpg magnets so
you know we would come to a stop and we
would patrol with foot patrol along with
the vehicle so the drivers would stay in
the gunner would stay in everyone else
would dismount
and we would foot patrol so we could get
a little space
if we were to get attacked we'd be able
to react in a much better way
because the vehicles are still are
basically stopped you're in a traffic
jam
you're in a traffic jam so i remember
and and
that is where you would notice different
areas you'd get a different
vibe from the people and and yes
as time went on the vibe shifted earlier
it was more positive and as as
a as we rolled into april and this is in
a shia zone you're talking about that
yeah
definitely definitely a shia zone so now
when we went down there for qrf it was
like yeah we were we were
not getting nice looks from people
coming from i was in the states at the
time i was in the navy
but
we weren't engaged right in iraq or
anything like that and you we
you we're we're experiencing something
uh we're experiencing abu ghraib when it
hits
something like the civilians experienced
it right so i can speak from that
perspective
um there were people
who had been starting to starting to
come in all along who said this is going
to be another vietnam
and they didn't just mean by that that
we were going to get bogged down and
our mission wasn't going to be
accomplished you know there was a moral
kind of uh commentary being made on what
we were doing over there
and those people who had been making the
argument that
america is this imperialist aggressor
going over there in this unjust
pre-emptive war
to attack the muslim world out of rage
for 911 or whatever it is
um
the iraq war in march 2003 at a 74
approval rating in a gallup poll
um now part of that is people
people like to win they expected to win
and if we had just cleaned it up it
would have stayed
even if abu ghraib had happened if we
had just cleaned up the war and won it i
think you know people like to win it
would have stayed that way
but as it starts to seem like we're
losing control of the country
and in an election year that's a big
part of this as well this is in 2004
it's you know six
five months six months before an
election a presidential election
those pictures hit the news there were a
lot of
there are a lot of moderate people not
hardcore
anti-war people or anything like that
who start to ask wait a second like
not only are we seeing do we seem to be
losing control of the country over there
what are we doing like it seems like
we're losing control of
of ourselves and when
i think it was i was only two weeks
after that i believe
that yeah it was two weeks after that
news hit
that zarqawi put out the nick berg tape
and all of a sudden the american people
this is uh the first
um american that was beheaded by al
qaeda in iraq over there
and all of a sudden americans are
they're thinking of war in very
different terms
rather than thinking of it as a
liberation
operation that of course there's
civilian casualties there's going to be
some messy things that happen there's
even going to be some soldiers that do
some things that they go out and do
now there seems to be this situation
where there is
some very very dark things going on in
this incredibly chaotic place and we are
just
that we're starting to get caught up in
that and we're just one element of
darkness
in this dark place because i think
americans they didn't wanna
they didn't want to
think or believe that about themselves
and when you see those pictures uh
you know they are incredibly shocking
for people who are just civilians i mean
i think they're probably shocking for
people who have seen violence as well
because
there's a certain there's a certain
macabre aspect
to a lot of them and the casual nature
with which
some of those reservists were
uh were posing with some of those
inmates
and i happen to be i don't know where
you fall on this i can like i happen to
be
uh of the of the mind that i
abu ghraib makes me enraged at the
the high level uh political people who
set the conditions
for that place to happen i don't i don't
um
i don't give myself the right to draw
harsh judgments
on the soldiers and the mps who were
there
the ones who actually got punished i
wasn't there
they were i'm not saying it was right or
justified or anything like
that i'm saying that you had this
this group of reservists from west
pennsylvania
who were put into a situation they're
absolutely not trained for
they were trained as combat support mps
they were not trained as prison guards
and they are put into
in an absurd situation under incredible
stress
in a prison that's in a combat zone um
you know abu ghraib is it's between
fallujah and baghdad right right in
there somewhere
it's sort of north of the airport it's
sort of north so so it's so it's
northwest of baghdad and it was a bad
area yes you're right it was in a combat
zone they're taking fire
at the prison um and
now maybe as somebody who is over there
and had to be responsible for your
behavior and for the behavior of your
men you can feel more comfortable
coming down straight on the directly on
the people who are involved
i just don't i don't like to do that i
wasn't there um i don't justify it
but i don't know what do you think what
do you think i think
um i would assume that
obviously you talk a lot about
leadership and so the people who set the
conditions and created
those conditions are going to be
important but um
i would maybe i would just uh assume
because i know other people who served
in iraq who do hold the people who were
directly involved with those things the
soldiers there the mps
very responsible because yeah i was over
there in iraq too
there were times that i wanted to beat
the hell out of somebody or do this but
i didn't
and they did and that's on them and look
what they cost us
and i get that and i don't gain say i
don't contradict them and say well what
about these
that's their right to have that view and
i don't give myself that right
um but i mean tell me what you think
well yeah
you you called it when when i see some
front line troops doing something that
they shouldn't be doing
sure they shouldn't be doing that whose
fault is it that they're doing that
it's easy to say it's their fault sure
um but
as leaders guess what if if you
have troops you're responsible for their
actions
that's the way it is that's the way it
is and
if you have to understand people well
enough that's why i talk about human
nature all the time
you're going to tell me you're going to
take 19
20 21 22 year old kids
from western pennsylvania that are
reservists that have very limited
limited military training and what
you're going to do is you're going to
take them and put them
in charge of the detainee the
a bunch of detainees that they think are
terrorists
while they're being attacked on a daily
basis if you don't think
if you if you can't see what could
unfold there you're
you're not having you you don't
understand human nature very well
so what does that mean you
as a leader you're responsible for
telling everyone hey this these are the
rules this is what's in place
this is why it's important if al jazeera
sees
us and i i'll use al jazeera and i think
they're
they're and you you probably well i know
you you probably will
understand their arc of of the way al
jazeera
has
what al jazeera has been because al
jazeera kind of started as a as a sort
of
almost like a secular kind of anti-like
extremist uh broadcast
the way al jazeera english still
primarily i've got arabic speaking
friends who send me over stuff it's
very very different in the arab language
version so
so the the at the time
what al jazeera was to us was they're
going to take
whatever we do and they're going to spin
it to anti-american
you know in an anti-american way so that
was always my kind of like warning to
guys look if al jazeera sees you doing
something
you're it's going to be an it's going to
be a massive uh you know
strategic hit a little tactical move
that you make
could be a massive negative strategic
hit or negative to to what goes on in
the war
so when those guys are doing that when
those male and female
detainee handlers do that yeah
sure do they deserve some punishment
absolutely
could that have been prevented and
should it have been prevented it
absolutely should have
and i had you know we we were running
detainee
operations as well so my seals would go
and
capture someone and bring them back
and put them in a in a temporary holding
facility
and we would stand watch on them that's
what would happen
this is also not a smart idea you know
you you you i'm gonna go
capture you was just shooting you're
trying to kill us
now we get a hold of you we bring you
back and now now we're responsible for
your safety
and comfort this that's not a good plan
this
it's not a good plan there needs to be a
level of detachment there
so yeah that's a that's a leadership
issue
and you've got to understand this goes
back to the conversation that we had
about
you know hey you got a sadist in your
platoon and you've got to have that
consideration you've got to
you've got an [ __ ] in your platoon
you know you've got an [ __ ] you're
you're
you've got 25 people that are
that are guards at this prisoner one of
them's going to be an [ __ ]
one of them is going to say hey if i get
the chance i'm going to slap one of
these guys around hey if i get the
chance i'm going to abuse these people
that's what i'm going to do
you got someone on the other end of that
spectrum that they under they'll they'll
get it and they would put a stop to that
and you've got everyone else in the
middle
and so when that guy's not when the good
guy is not on watch this [ __ ] happens
well yeah there is that but i i i tend
to think of abu ghraib as the
as the culmination of a lot of the bad
decisions we talked about yesterday not
being able to provide security in the
country
not having which leads to not having
enough intelligence
which leads to general obazide saying i
need more intelligence go get me
actionable intelligence and so you have
all the stuff with
you know the fourth id going out there
and just doing mass roundups and
bringing people in whole villages that
they're bringing in because we gotta we
don't know the difference we don't have
any human intelligence yet
they're all getting sent to abu ghraib
because we don't have anywhere else to
keep them
abu ghraib is the prison that is like
the symbol of saddam's
brutal power right this had execution
chambers torsh
this is where you got did not want to
get sent if you were under saddam's
regime we started sending all of these
people there
huge number by the by the army's own
estimate 70 80 percent of them
ended up free of charges didn't need to
be there um
they get in there and a lot of people
don't know the whole story
uh of abu ghraib they get stuck on the
the
grotesque pictures and everything these
reservists
from western pennsylvania they get sent
into this place it is
vastly overcrowded and undermanned to to
you know
in uh i believe in september of
03 they basically got the number of
guards that they were going to have
until
the next spring meanwhile the population
of the prison doubles
and then it doubles again they don't
have the manpower to do this
you've got these 18 19 20 year old kids
who they walk into this situation and
they are people are already being
stood on boxes naked by military
intelligence they're already being
you know pinned up against walls and
trust up like in stressed positions this
is already going on when
they arrive right and so i'm i try to
put myself in this situation
where you know yes you're supposed to
disobey
an unlawful order right if you see
something that's going on there's an
open door policy and you're supposed to
go on but
if i'm a 19 year old or 20 year old i
don't know
anything about war i know what i've seen
on tv right and so i show up the first
day
and this stuff is already going on they
didn't invent this it wasn't these
little group of guys that
you know that went completely off the
rails and nobody knew about it it was
this dark thing that happened
occasionally like at night time
you know the famous picture where you
have the pile of naked guys
that was the screen saver on the
computer in the in the military police
office
everybody knew what was going on there
were times when these kids would go
to medics go to other people and show
them pictures and be like is this
authorized can i do this and they're
like well
the famous picture of uh lindy england
the female
who was not supposed to be on the block
by the way she was dating one of the
guys
on the block she's from a completely
different area she's not cleared to be
there gives you an idea how the
discipline had broken down right
but she's coming just to hang out with
her boyfriend every night and they're
goofing around with the prisoners and
there's the famous one where she's
walking the naked guy
on a leash so we would end up
uh we we ended up with abu ghraib with a
bunch of people who were
mentally ill right there wasn't like a
bunch of psychiatric
prisoners the prisoners yeah right the
prisoners there weren't a bunch of
functional psychiatric mental health
facilities all over iraq at the time and
so
we would be out there and a lot of times
these people who were mentally ill would
give our soldiers problems and you know
uh we would be like okay this guy's a
problem take them in and we would take
them in and then they would get into the
general population
just to even clarify that more when you
say give them problems this is just
someone that's not doing what you're
telling them to do
because they don't understand they're
they're scared
and you're you're a 22 year old soldier
and you look at the guy and go
you know i i can't judge what's
happening but this guy's not doing what
i tell him to do
but zip him up and we bring the guy in
he's unmanageable in the general
population so we sent him over to the
hard site where we actually have
individual cells and we put them in
there and
um they're trying to get this guy he's
spitting on people this guy in question
the one
in that picture he's spitting on people
he's throwing feces at people he takes
off his own clothes they didn't strip
him
okay um and he goes and gets a tie strap
for a from a humvee
and he puts it around his shoulders to
like walk this guy over
and the guy goes down on his hands and
knees and the strap comes up around his
neck so it looks like a leash
and uh they're walking him to the place
that they're trying to bring him and he
actually
the guy uh grainer who's like kind of
he's supposed to be the real sadist in
the group and he has some statistic
tendencies there's no question about
that he took that picture
and he took it to the medics and he
explained the situation of what happened
and said is this
like this is what happened is this okay
and they gave they said well you know
under the circumstances you know i mean
that seems fine
and so you know this this was the
environment
that these 19 20 21 year old reservists
who are not trained to be prison guards
are finding themselves in here and i
think one of the other things that blows
me away
um it just blows me away that this is
how it is
is that you know the military
intelligence
folks the interrogators they wanted to
be able to kind of play some good cop
bad cop and
you know be the uh kind of uh
be able to build a relationship with
some of these people they're trying to
interrogate in various ways depending on
who they are and it was the military
police
who were in charge of kind of setting
the conditions in the place and
making sure that the prisoners were in a
sufficient level of discomfort
so that when they went in to be
interrogated
the military police the military
intelligence guys the interrogators
could kind of play that good cop side
and so you have now now that is
something you're supposed to
walk this fine line between
you know setting conditions to make
people properly uncomfortable
and abuse like that fine line
and that is something that should
require extraordinary training
and discipline right that is a hard hard
thing to do especially when you're
talking about unsophisticated 20 year
old reservists
who are dealing with jihadis
you're dealing with guys who are you
know maybe a he was a colonel in the
in saddam's army and you got to think of
like what kind of
you know just adaptable savvy
cockroach you gotta be to survive that
long
you know under saddam and make your way
through the system and now i am a guy
who doesn't speak arabic
and i've got to figure out how to make
this guy do what i want him to do
and i have no ways to control this guy
who's looking at me
he's just not taking me remotely
seriously and i can sense that
uh i have no way to control this guy
other than force
in order to make him respect my
authority and comply with what i
they're just they were not they were
they were absolutely not prepared to be
in that situation
and i blame the people who put them
there and who created the conditions for
that to happen i don't know
i don't know i don't know what group of
20 year old reservists you could have
put into a situation like that
that would have handled it well would
they have done what they did i'll tell
you what group
a group that had a good leader you have
a good leader that explains what's going
on
these things an american soldier
reservist active duty doesn't matter
you you put good leadership over those
individuals and they will
do what they're supposed to do that
that's what happens and i've seen this
over and over and over again in my time
in in the us military
working with soldiers working with
marines meeting 18 year old kids 20 year
old kids
if if you lead them correctly they will
absolutely do what they are supposed to
do if you don't
if you don't well then they're gonna
they're gonna go where nature takes them
and and you know another thing we have
to remember is and you know this was my
sort of initial reaction
was like oh whatever
you know uh when i joined the seal teams
you know it's a it was a it's a very uh
very violent culture and a very
hard culture to be a part of and you
know we got
haze we got we got hazed significantly
and
and that's just the way it was so every
single one of those pictures
i was like oh yeah you know we we i've
been there
on the ground you know i've been that
guy i've been beat up i've been been
taped up i've been hung up i've been all
those things um
you know that that's that's normal every
day and then you take it one step
further
you look at the whole navy uh oh
when i went through the shell back
ceremony uh
not quite as bad as a seal team hazing
but it was a big authorized hazing
and then i was like oh what about sears
school well what happened to me it's
your school oh guess what they're doing
to you
it's your school they're slapping you
around you know you're
you're naked you're you're being abused
that's the way it is you're freezing um
they're putting you in stress positions
it's all the same stuff
so from my my you know my
my initial reaction was like yeah well
whatever these are these are terrorists
and by the way
you you contrast that against the fact
that zarqawi is
sawing people's heads off right and i'm
like wait a second
the enemy is sawing people's heads off
and i'm supposed to be mad at this
reservist
because she walked a guy around with a
leash look
that's that's and that and you know what
that is actually the reality
that that's the reality that's the
reality of what happened
well when you compare what was going on
in there to what was going on in there
under
in that same facility under saddam yeah
a year and a half
and here's the deal even though that's
the reality of what happened
it didn't matter it didn't matter
everything i just said
had no had no it did nothing
to paint to clean up the picture that
got put out
by the insurgent and the the al jazeera
media
and really and our own media that posted
these pictures over and over again with
no explanations
and and you know you show that to an
iraqi this is what the americans are
doing to
us this is
in abu ghraib this is absolutely what
this this added this is why i said on
the last episode this is what
added so much fuel to the fire
that it became yeah this is this is this
is
uh a turning point and that is why from
a leadership perspective
everybody on your team has to understand
that their tactical decisions can have
strategic
impacts and that is an example i use all
the time at echelon front
of a tactical decision that had
strategic impact on an entire war
that that's exactly like you know you
want to look at bremer and you want to
talk about
you know disbanning the iraqi police in
the iraqi military yeah that's a
strategic
blunder and it had strategic
implications
but this is a tactical blunder
committed by frontline troops e3s and
e4s
that had a massive strategic negative
impact on the war
there's a lesson to be learned from that
all day long also
and i'll go back and forth with people
on this as well
you know how could i have been
responsible
if i was the if i was the
if i was the company commander if i was
the battalion commander if i was in
charge that person how can i be
responsible for what those front-line
troops do
and that right there is just where
everything falls apart
because the minute you have people
saying hey it's not my responsibility
what the frontline troops do
that's the complete wrong answer it's
the complete wrong answer
you have to do the proper training you
have to give them the proper
understanding of what the mission is you
have to under give them an understanding
of
what the impact of their mission is what
the parameters are they have to
understand you as a leader are
absolutely responsible for that
and when we fail to lead this is the
kind of thing that happens
i agree and i and i agree that it was
ugly when people started scrambling for
cover rather than taking responsibility
um after it happened um although there's
evidence that they were getting
political pressure put on them to do
that remember this is an election year
and
i mean to me like the idea that
nobody in the upper echelon of the
defense department resigned their
position over abu ghraib
just blows me away but the bush
administration was in a point where
we're in the middle of a close election
this we have to just put this on you
know these e2s and e3s and e4s on the
ground and like wash our hands of this
when there was a lieutenant colonel in
the prison who knew what was going on
there were jag officers who came through
that prison and
uh you know there was an incident where
grainer that you know the main kind of
the main ringleader guy
um he had this game where he would have
hooded prisoners and he would like to
just
jokingly kind of walk him around and get
him disoriented and then walk him into a
wall
and one of them got a bloody nose and so
you know a
medic saw it and cleaned him up and
everything and they decided they needed
to counsel greaner over give him a
counseling chit right
and now normally for non-military people
out there a counseling [ __ ] is like sort
of a reprimand
right we have this counseling [ __ ] it's
been you know it's been printed in
newspapers and stuff it's not
at all it just kind of says like hey
you're doing a great job
if you need any kind of clarification on
the rules or anything or if you're under
too much stress make sure you talk to us
but keep up the great work and you know
this was after a guy had just walked the
prisoner into a wall
and uh made his nose bleed which again
like in the context of al qaeda in the
context of saddam hussein
in the context of being a new guy in a
seal platoon right so like if i got away
with just a bloody nose and walk into a
wall i'd be pretty stoked so the fact
that
the fact that that was your initial
reaction this is interesting
um the fact that that was your kind of
initial reaction and i think it was a
lot of people's initial reaction it's
like well okay yeah but we're still not
them
it tells me though that at this point in
the war
uh we still did not realize that we were
fighting
we were running a counter insurgency i i
think
you're you're right that we didn't
realize and i don't think we were
i think that this is what turned this is
what
this is what solidified the insurgency
okay this this is what turned it from
hey some iraqis that you know
you take you take 20 iraqis that the
month prior
still had that american flag in their
back pocket for when the when the tide
changed
all of a sudden they were like oh no and
and you know
10 of those 20 threw that american flag
away at that point
i found it interesting uh somebody i've
heard somebody say one time i don't
remember if it was in the context of abu
ghraib or not
they were talking about you know
you don't need uh you don't need sadist
for something like this to happen you
have a bunch of inexperienced people
under extraordinary stress who are not
trained to handle the situation that
they're in
and from even from the political level
from the administration because it's in
the press people are watching the news
that there's a debate going on
should torture be allowed where should
should we move the definition of torture
over a little bit or not so
that's in the air that there's some
permissiveness going on they walk into a
situation where
everything that we saw in those pictures
was already happening
and they're told this is what military
intelligence wants well i'm an e2 i just
showed up to the war am i going to be
like
well i don't know any better i say okay
i know what i've seen in movies and on
tv but i guess this is real war and this
is
how real war actually is so i'm not
going to say anything
um and they they get into that situation
um but it's not it's you don't have to
have people
ordered to do it you don't have to have
um you know
all you need is a certain amount of
permissiveness and the way the person
put it was if you think there was
if imagine if there was a bar in san
diego
or los angeles where it was just you
could
go in there and there was a person and
you could just go punch them and insult
them
and whatever so you get get done with
work and you can just go home and have a
beer
you and your buddies you had a stressful
day and you go in there you can slap
this guy around
and not everybody would do it but that
place wouldn't be empty
it wouldn't be empty and just
just by making it allowed and not having
i mean there's a reason that the army is
that the military is an institution of
discipline
right is you are gearing people up to go
face
an extraordinarily difficult task which
involves killing and being killed
19 year old kids who who were working at
a at a mechanics garage
four months ago you know and you have to
get them in the mindset that they can
deal with
killing somebody and with people trying
to kill them and with their friends
being killed and
where this is not a distant reality
where you know smart bombs are taking
out
iraqi high-value targets while we're
kind of over here in kuwait
abu ghraib is getting hit with mortars
all the time
and so it's right there going on and the
people that they're processing into this
prison they're being told these are the
people who are firing those at you
these are the people who if they overrun
this prison or if they get loose
and there's like a prison break or
something we'll chop your head off
without a second thought and that was
true of some of them
right and these 19 year olds have to
figure out how to
be the authority figure in a situation
like that and it is just
you know all of the decisions from brum
you know this is like the reason i said
it
uh you know the decision to go in with
too few troops against the advice of the
military so that we couldn't control the
country
and we didn't have the resource all of
those decisions are why those kids
ended up in that place under those
conditions
you know yeah and it's also um again
it's a lack of understanding of human
nature
yeah right what's that what's the famous
experiment at stanford where they
you know the prison experiment yeah the
stanford prison experiment right
does everyone not know that if you put
people into a position of authority
they're gonna start to abuse their power
and now you set the conditions like you
just said
these are these are terrorists in my
mind you know these are terrorists
and i'm a good guy they're bad guys and
i'm being told actually to make sure
they're uncomfortable cool i got this
where do you think that's going to end
up where do you think that's going to
end up
especially if you're not trained i mean
just think about like if you're in
charge
say the stanford prison experiment you
don't need sadism right
to explain it like just i'm in an
authority position
there's a person over there on the other
side who's telling me to [ __ ] off
and now i gotta figure out how to make
him compliant now there's ways to do it
but if you got to be pretty
sophisticated to do that to do it
without resorting to force or coercion
you can do it
but you got to be pretty sophisticated
you know you got to be kind of an alpha
personality you have to have ways to do
it
they were not they were not given any of
those tools they were just told
be the man control these people these
are terrorists and when these people got
non-compliant
they don't have any tools to handle
these guys except for force and
humiliation and and
those are the tools that they have you
know and
it was just uh it was it was an awful
awful situation
um when it happened and um
and it became pretty clear very shortly
after that that we were looking at
something
like an insurgency as i said very
quickly in my
estimation that event and the
the way that it got portrayed
absolutely solidified the insurgency
without without a doubt in my mind and
if you kind of look at the
look there was there was the insurgency
was
starting to gel a little bit right
a little bit you know you had pockets
here you had pockets there you know you
you were just talking about what was
happening in the job what was happening
in sadder city what was happening in
fallujah like you had stuff going on
but there were still iraqis that were
like you know
i hope the americans can pull this off
and
when that happened yeah all that all
those little p
pieces that were floating around all of
a sudden started to gel
were you you know you had been taking
out
a lot of criminals gangsters people like
that
during your first tour um
had you seen enough by that point that
when
the nick berg tape came out in uh may of
2004
that that did not surprise you did you
already have an idea of
that these are the people we were kind
of dealing with
i think that the fallujah bridge
yeah that was the that that would to me
was the first indicator
of okay i see where this is going and
then nick berg was an excellent
exclamation point on that
when you uh i mean you were processing
back probably by that point to start
your tours
the admirals aid i mean were you just
like screw that send me back
like turn me loose on these people yeah
i mean
it was really hard the it was it was a
real
it was a when i when i was
when i was pleading with my boss to
plead with his boss
to plead with his boss to let us go to
fallujah
and and and help in that situation and
we got stood down
that was a hard pill for me to swallow i
was very i was very
disappointed about that
you know i was very disappointed about
that and it kind of left a mark
and yeah that was that was a hard that
was a hard one
you know um and actually
those guys okay so one of them scott
halveston was it was a seal and
those guys had come to my compound
[Music]
we stayed in a compound in in baghdad
those contractors yes okay those
contractors
came to my compound and they had kind of
just shown up
um at least that's the impression that i
got was that they had just shown up
and so we had a conversation with them
and
i remember like i was like talking with
someone remember i said my um my platoon
chief was a like an off-road guy
and and so he was all dialed on vehicles
and
and so we're sitting there talking to
him and
i remember asking him or either that or
but it was probably my chief asked him
because he was had the mindset
of vehicles and he was like do you guys
have run flats
because they had these armored these
armored um
like ford explorers which was kind of
what everyone was driving
the armored ford explorers were crap um
they
they didn't all they did was add armor
like the
the minimum kind of armor but there was
no adjustments to the suspension
so they were just kind of crap
and i remember my my platoon chief
asking i was pretty sure it was him
saying do you guys have run flats
meaning if you get a flat tire
can you keep going and their answer was
no
and so you know you had you kind of had
a bad feeling this is
now that when you're asking me this
question which you you seem to
want to know if i sense the escalation
this is one of the things where as i
think back on it
the i this is where we knew things were
escalating
because we were looking at these guys
saying hey
do you guys have run flats because if
you're going into fallujah we knew were
there when
where they were going yeah and they got
ambushed and they got ambushed and i'll
have to i'll have to actually go back
and ask my platoon chief if it was
that crew but i'm almost positive
and again uh forgive my memory man this
is yeah yeah this is
let's happen between now and then lots
happen between between now and then and
i'm glad we're talking about it
but there was contractors that were not
prepared
and three months prior you could run
around in baghdad
however you wanted to and you'd be fine
two months prior
you'd be running around in baghdad you
might want to check yourself a little
bit
you know starting to get into march
you'd be like
okay we need to think about this now
in april we're looking at these guys
going do you have run flats in case you
get a flat tire because if you get a
flat tire
you you lose your mobility you're gonna
lose your survivability
so that is what that that is the kind of
thing that we were thinking about
and then those seeing those guys
you know strung up from the bridges from
the bridge
and then nick berg it was like okay yeah
this is
this is this is gonna get worse
that's the only uh it's the only one of
those videos i've watched
i made myself watch the nick berg one
when it first came out and i
after that i was like i i don't need to
watch another one i've seen it
um i thought about watching the foley
one when it came out but um
you know nick berg by all accounts he's
a great kid he's a little eccentric and
um you know who he reminds me of in
certain ways
if you've ever read the book or seen the
movie into the wild
yeah about chris mccandless he kind of
reminds me of that guy where he's a
little bit naive
maybe he's idealistic just like those
contractors though who had no idea
apparently what country they were in and
a lot of people didn't yet
yeah that was another thing like you'd
see contractors and at this point
look i'm not we were by no means like
battle hardened
you know guys because our our first
deployment we got in
a few fire fights um playing the game on
god mode
yeah we we but we had done a lot of
operations yeah and we were good we were
good at what we were doing like when you
saw our convoy
you know when you saw our convoy
maneuver through the streets we were
really good you know
if we had a flat tire we looked like a
nascar pit crew
you know again my platoon chief
you know running guys through drills my
my leading petty officer running guys
through drills
the guys in the platoons just locked on
and so we you know we
like i said we weren't battle hardened
but we'd done a lot of operations
and we'd see it's like the classic
you know what i talked about this with
some of the sog guys i've had on my
podcast
or and even just any of the vietnam guys
that classic scene that you see in the
movies
of the new guy getting off the plane in
saigon and you know with his brand new
clean camis on
and you know a fresh haircut and freshly
shaven credence playing in the
background and credence playing in the
background and then you know who does he
come across he comes across
the long-haired hardened thousand-yard
stare
gear totally trashed um not even trashed
but broken in
i remember looking at these contractors
and you know they got brand new web gear
they got brand you know
they got brand new setup you can tell
that they haven't worn it very much
you know they might have done some
shooting drills or whatever so you're
you're
you're a little bit nervous when you see
guys like that
and because this is a different time too
as you get into 0.809
a lot of those contracts these are
former special ops guys these are a
bunch of guys with experience
these contractors a lot of these
contractors were guys
that had been in you know been in the
military been in the seal teams been in
the you know been to green bay or
whatever
you know four how much experience could
they have had well yeah that's what i'm
saying like they were
they were green beret in the 90s they
were a seal
in you know 1987. um you know
i i mean i met i had lunch with guys i
remember having lunch with guys you know
like teen guys
you know and they're they're your bros
and they're fired up to be over there
because you know as much as i talked
about uh
wanting to be in combat and had the luck
of
going getting to be in combat and i
talked about guys that have been in for
30 years that never were
well those guys got out and all of a
sudden opportunity came for them to lock
and load their weapons and
go do god's work and they took that
opportunity
but you know it's it i met plenty of
guys
especially because this is the this is
the actual time you know this is the
time when
black water and the rest of the the rest
of the contracting
gigs you know this is like 1200 1500
bucks a day
that's how what that's what the demand
signal was and the demand signal was we
want guys that were
special operations you know because they
had
at least have more training and it was
you know you fast forward three four
years and it was like
hey we'll take pretty much anybody um
especially because pretty much anybody
if you were in the military you know you
had
run convoys and you knew how to handle
yourself
it feels like with contractors
describing it that they
it doesn't sound like they had the same
kind of
overarching leadership structure that
was like looking after them that they
had like a looser
leadership structure that i mean the the
the idea that they were going into
fallujah
with you know when they couldn't run
flat and just all that like
who's making that decision to allow them
to do something like that yeah it was
that
experience for me that you know
1500 bucks a day but you couldn't have
given me enough money
to take those jobs because
i was just looking at them going man
like i'm i you know i'm
literally standing there looking at a
guy that has you know
whatever whatever dumb gear setup he had
where you're looking at you know he's
got his he's gonna get in a vehicle and
he's got his pistol
like you know whatever in a position
where he's never gonna be able to get
that thing out
or whatever dumb thing they had and
you're looking at him thinking like that
sucks and then you're looking at
you know over at one one of my guys who
has everything completely dialed in can
make things happen you know
immediately you know i i my assistant
platoon commander at the time was just
one of those kind of
kind of gear gear heads you know and
everything he was testing all the time
and i'm looking at him going
you know this guy you know my guy
is so eminently
prepared and i'm looking at this
contractor going
and what kind of comms do you guys have
you know there's a question that i'm
gonna ask right
that's you know my my platoon chief is
gonna go do you have run flats i'm going
to say
hey what kind of comms do you have
because i was a i was a radio man so
you know seal platoons you know that was
how i was raised and
and i'm the guy that's asking what kind
of comms do you have and they you know
you get the response of oh we have inner
squad radios
for you know the two cars so we can talk
to each other
oh what are you going to do if you get
in trouble well we have
what was it the whatever sat phone
you know satellite civilian satellite
communication thing
who are you going to call you see what
i'm you see where i'm going with this
this is just
all bad it's all bad and
that's why you know when you s when we
saw that unfold
it was you know it was horrible to see
it was it was horrible to see
and it caught them off guard
because contractors had been running
around the country doing all kinds of
work
good work good work yeah good work
providing security
you know running convoys for people they
were they were doing good work
and necessary work and saving you know
uh the government money because even
though those guys are getting paid 1500
bucks a day
at the end of the day that's way cheaper
than hiring or then bringing you know
bringing in an enlisted
man to go through the training and be on
the va
for the rest of his life like there's a
there's a cost benefit to it
and there's a cost benefit to them
because they have the opportunity to
make money so they were doing good work
but when things started to escalate and
you're and you know if you're blackwater
and you're bringing in contractors
you know you're bringing in contractors
in in
whatever four or five months earlier hey
give them a little training cool go run
a convoy they put their military
experience with their
little training they just got they got a
couple guys that have a little
experience you're good to go
they make it happen you you fast forward
to
sending them into fallujah and you see
the results yeah people didn't have
they didn't have an idea of what kind of
war we're in yet and i mean nick berg is
a perfect example of that he was a
you know if he would have gone to kosovo
to do what he did so he was 26 years old
um and he had a business he was kind of
an adventurous kid he did cross-country
bike rides that kind of thing and he had
a business
um where he would fix high-rise like
communications and transmission
equipment he would dangle 600 feet up in
the air and do repairs electrician
repairs
and he was good at it he wanted to start
his own business he had actually done
some work in kenya before where he would
go down and he would
kind of do humanitarian work and also
like pursue some business opportunities
in his mid-20s which is kind of a
fascinating kit most people aren't doing
that in their mid-20s he would have gone
to kosovo and done something like that
and you know the bad guys would have
come across him there
i might have held him for a while they
might have uh maybe he might have you
know caught a straight bullet or
something like that
but they weren't just looking for
americans and if they find you
they're going to kill you and publicize
it it was just a different kind of
it was a different kind of war and a
different kind of enemy
and i think people didn't realize that
that was the kind of war we were in yet
and um there's no mistaking it after
that nick berg tape
came out watching zarqawi
read that statement and then murder him
himself in such a grisly way and it took
so long
um that
especially with it coming right after
abu ghraib i think people just started
to get a very dark view of the war
and things only started to deteriorate
in the country in many ways from then
because is this i'm pretty pretty sure
that this is around the time when we
didn't really exactly know what we were
dealing with
we didn't exactly know who this enemy
was or where they were
and so we just kind of pulled back it
was an election year we didn't want a
lot of casualties
and we just started to pull back into
our bases and kind of did this
you know petraeus called it drive-by
counter insurgency where we're just
racing our convoys through an area and
going back to our bases
and meanwhile wide swaths of the country
are just being taken over by al-qaeda
and um you know there was a uh
well there was a strategic decision that
was made arguably
for what were a lot of political reasons
having to do with domestic politics and
also i think
because we just didn't we didn't expect
to be in this war this is not the war
that we planned for
um we had people right just like this
happens in a lot of wars we had people
who knew what kind of war this was
and they were ready to fight this war
you know petraeus had been up by himself
in mosul
with the 101st all this time most soil
for anybody is another map of iraq is
way way way up in the north far away so
he had some level of autonomy from what
was going on in baghdad and everything
and this is a guy with a phd
who literally wrote the book right on
counter insurgency and
and he and he's the man i mean he knows
what he's talking about he studied this
stuff
and he was handling mosul in a very
different way he understood the hearts
and minds aspect he understood the fact
that we have to win over this population
if we're going to actually
you know provide any stability and build
something here and
you know the particular enemy that we
had al qaeda
so dark you forget about flying planes
into buildings
okay i mean that's a that was an evil
act and everything but
something like that i can honestly just
put it as a you know what this is a
terrorist action
but they're attacking a symbol of
american power for their sort of broad
strategic reasons
and and fine the kind of interpersonal
savagery that al qaeda and iraq was
engaging in to the point where
eventually
you know osama bin laden said we need to
pull back from these guys right
um that they gave us this opportunity
it was it would have been just on a
silver platter to say to the iraqi
people
look this is your other option we're the
good guys here we're going to make
mistakes
some of our soldiers are going to do
some bad things but you know saddam was
here and now these are your other
options
we're the we're your best option here
and
you know because of abu ghraib and
because we had this lack of
understanding
and we were trying to make up for those
early mistakes for a couple years right
um we we just we it took three years
until 2006 you know before we really
started to real
put some people in charge who knew what
was going on and were ready to take
action and take risks
you know and that's we're going to get
into that in the next episode here but i
want to talk about like just what a huge
gamble ramadi was
and how you know people think the
american military is like well
it's really just a matter of focus like
as soon as we decide we want to
go do something you know we might be
have we we might be making bad decisions
for political reasons we might have a
muddled mission
or whatever but if we actually decide to
go do something then it's over and then
we'll just go do it right
um at the time it was there were people
who thought the ramadi mission was
suicidal
that there was no way you guys were
going to pull that off and there was so
much writing on it because if you hadn't
pulled it off
and it hadn't gone the way that it went
i mean i the surge wouldn't have
happened no you know i and
um as you're back home
and you're watching the news i mean you
must have had
and hearing stories from guys who are
coming back and guys who are over there
you must have had sort of a this this
creeping
uh understanding coming up that like
when you go back to a you're going back
and b when you go back like it's going
to be on
let's talk about that on the next
episode because there's a whole
story behind that
um well if you're listening to this
podcast
on the jaco podcast feed it's now on its
own feed
as well and eventually we'll separate
those so if you want to
hear these types of stories subscribe to
this podcast if you want to listen to it
you can also check out our other
podcasts
i have a podcast called jaco podcast the
warrior kid podcast as well
and then i have a more lighthearted
podcast called grounded and daryl
has a not so lighthearted podcast
called martyr made and if you want to
support
any and all of these podcasts you can do
so by getting some gear
from jocko store or from origin
maine.com
thanks for listening as things
unravel this is jocko and daryl
out